erasmus tout le monde connaît un
programme de mobilité pour les étudiants
eh bien non c'est plus que ça erasmus
plus c'est un programme de mobilité pour
tous les jeunes quelles que soient leurs
cursus mêmes quel que soit leur âge
parce qu'on peut partir dès le primaire
ce que j'ai beaucoup travaillé au sein
d'erasmus plus c'est la question de la
mobilité européenne des apprentis
pourquoi parce que la mobilité on le
sait elle mène à l'emploi elle permet
d'acquérir des nouvelles compétences
formels et informels la langue
l'adaptabilité le la rencontre de
nouvelles cultures on rentre plus riches
et donc plus employables donc erasmus
plus c'est désormais un programme qui
était doublée sur sa partie budgétaire
et surtout qui a intégré de nouvelles
catégories de citoyens et de jeunes
l'apprentissage notamment faire partir
les apprentis c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué parce que nous n'avons pas
cette culture dans nos entreprises et
parce que nous avons beaucoup de
fonctionnement différent l'échelle
européenne maintenant avec un rat smith
plus les mobilités longue des apprentis
son permis c'est à dire que ça permet de
donner des bourses aux jeunes qui sont
éligibles à ces programmes il faut que
les entreprises s'en saisisse il faut
que les centres de formation des
apprentis s'en saisissent et c'est comme
ça qu'on va bâtir cette europe de
l'apprentissage pour que encore une fois
tous les jeunes encore plus de jeunes
puissent partir se former acquérir des
compétences formelle informel acquérir
des langues et une adaptabilité pour le
monde du travail moi même je travaille
au sein de la fondation eurois mobility
pour convaincre nos chefs d'entreprise
les cfa de simplifier tout le dispositif
est de permettre ces mobilités donc pour
acquérir 2 vos profils mais surtout
parce que l'union européenne a besoin de
mettre en ligne toutes ses compétences
pour la transition écologique et pour
tous les progrès sur le numérique